thank you
[Music]
so everything that's going on in the
world economy it's pretty crazy between
China and U.S and Russia and [ __ ]
everywhere else no I was really
surprised to see that Apple who has its
chips uh manufactured in Taiwan has now
asked Taiwan to remove anything that
says Made in Taiwan Apple yeah they
wanted to say it can only from now on
all the Apple products could only say
made in Taiwan China or made in Chinese
Taipei
wow it's on now big big move do you
think it's because Apple doesn't want to
lose their China account yeah
of the world dude China has everybody
about the balls so that's Apple's saying
team China then that's Apple saying
we've got to protect our slave laborer
in China but it's kind of that's what's
because they're it's made in China right
it's made in the chips are made in
Taiwan because remember oh but it's
assembled in China in the factories I
think it's also wildly sold in China
it's like a big thing too you know so
then
that's so so they've officially asked
for and we're so used to seeing made in
Taiwan like in Hot Wheels cars there's
little things little things everywhere
if Apple's gonna start doing that
probably going to be the end of seeing
that there's another name for China I
mean a Taiwan though and it's called
like the Republic of China or some [ __ ]
or like people yeah people's Republicans
no but there's so that's uh people are
playing I think that's China That's
China Republic of China Republic of
China's Taiwan so when I because at the
um at my old University [ __ ] um Cal
State LA there's a huge statue of
Confucius and then there's a plaque that
says Confucius say Confucius say this is
donated by the Republic of only take one
fortune cookie at a time I didn't know
that because I was like damn this whole
[ __ ] place is communist funded and
then my friend was like no that's
actually Taiwan so I was like oh I
didn't know that I didn't know that
either yeah so they wanted to say to
specify exactly wow Taiwan Kama China or
Chinese Taipei so how many other
companies or countries now are gonna
have to start like pretty much pulling
straws right like which team you're on
yeah dude John Cena bro
he pulled away which yeah dude that's
all the straws John Cena [ __ ] in in
Chinese saying I'm so sorry for calling
Taiwan a country this Chinese is really
good it was really yeah they're still
shooting off Rockets right now
as like it's like five days in a room
Pelosi left they like basically did
according with tanks right she [ __ ] it
all up dude didn't like Snickers
recently have to apologize or some [ __ ]
or Twix or something yes I saw that boy
they say sorry we like Taiwan well I
don't know if it was accident but there
was like a promotional thing they were
doing and they were like oh this
promotion is only for the countries of
this this and Taiwan and then China was
like yo did you just call that a country
and it came in and they were like they
were looking at it like Snickers like oh
my bad that we that was like a little
mistake I heard trying to actually said
they were like
for real bro you don't do me like that
yeah
Snickers how you gonna do me that's what
I wrote
wow
[ __ ] disappointment to put that in
words yeah I don't know it was a gift do
you know um it's a wisely used Chinese
if you're family members in Taiwan are
like oh [ __ ] we better get the [ __ ] out
of here or like I haven't really so my
mom just came back not too long ago I
haven't really talked to my uncle in a
bit
um but I think obviously like every
country they never want to alarm their
citizens so the times that I've talked
to them they always go oh it's pretty
chill here like they don't see the
rockets and stuff that's the thing I
don't know like just kind of like how
America doesn't really tell us the real
[ __ ] either right but America does a
great job of amplifying everybody else's
[ __ ] no we don't try to alarm anybody we
just say like hey monkey pox is probably
gonna kill literally everybody on Earth
we were late
dude seriously and you get it for
kissing dudes for kissing boys kissing
boys gonna spread that around right
that's all it is I also feel like it's
like a one day takeover
if China wants to so without aware of
Taiwan yeah so yeah like a lot of the
anti like missile defense systems and
whatever that they had they're so
outdated in Taiwan or China in Taiwan
and that [ __ ] doesn't even work no more
damn dude because all the best [ __ ]
they've been making is like being
manufactured for other countries but
they rely on the U.S military like a lot
of countries they just rely on the U.S
help so without even like declaring
whose side you're on do you think Taiwan
has a chance against China I don't think
so not without the West is hell it
doesn't look like it nah Wes is already
I think yeah I don't think without the
West's help and I think uh that's the
only way
well that's the only reason why China
hasn't swallowed Taiwan yet is because
like America always made its presence do
you feel like the West has enough of a
mutual benefit to want to step in and do
this yeah those microchips dude isn't
trying to making hella money off Taiwan
though it was the other way around
before because a lot of Taiwanese
citizens would go to China and build
factories and then they would be the
connection to the West so a lot of
Taiwanese people became wealthy by being
partners with Chinese citizens and
creating factories and being
manufactured for uh the us or the west
but China's profiting from that too
right yeah I mean they're in Partnership
but before there was no bridge to the
west but now they can directly
manufacture and there's you know
everyone all over the world is going
directly to China to manufacture but
yeah Taiwan used to be the bridge but
taiwan's just basically like the
microchip capital of the world and they
they manufacture a lot of stuff there
and I don't know
um how China would be profiting from
that because they're autonomous as in
like they don't give them any tax money
or anything like that well what if they
just renamed Taiwan like would China
care rename it what like it's like South
China or some [ __ ] I think that's just I
think that's what China wants right yeah
or they call it call it call it the
China but China
can you imagine can you guys imagine
China
are you kidding me are you kidding me
hey hey hey hey hey
Read that read that read that what to
say we're gonna say It's Made
the China
are you kidding me
pretty [ __ ] nuts that's what you get
if you rename her that's what you get
it's a blast for everybody
just for that everybody has a great time
there's no war
everyone is a great time there's no war
there's no [ __ ] [ __ ] hey if
you're from Taiwan you get to be like oh
where are you from you'd be like yeah
vagina vagina
so what were you saying Ryan because the
longest that I've ever heard of like the
whole beef which has been going on since
like I was a kid
um I've never heard what China actually
wants
besides you need to go back to we need
to be like one nation come back to Papa
I've never heard of like what the actual
like
business or monetary or political or
like military like any type of other
incentive besides
Taiwan belongs to China and we need to
own it this kind of mirrors Russia's
reason for Ukraine though they're like
you guys are Russians you should be a
part of us and I think China does that
to Taiwan or vagina but does it but does
Russia rely on
Ukrainian exports at all Ukraine does
wheat to the world and also uh natural
gases or some [ __ ] like that or like
there's a huge reserve of oil or natural
gases and is there any um military
advantages for like you know uh having
Taiwan based off of like location and
stuff like that too oh you want to say
vagina
would you like me to stay with China
what we're gonna say well I was gonna
say the military Advantage is like is
like that that they're dropping bombs
now into Virginia
get this guy [ __ ] inhaler right now
right well that's the joke is the Weezy
laugh yeah it has to go with the witch
laugh it doesn't work it's the Jew it's
the New Jersey Uncle you know exactly
the guy that has the best the guy with
with a lot of gold like embedded into
his neck because he never took his
necklace on yeah yeah I don't know if
it's quite like um like Hawaii to U.S
yeah where that's a very geographical
the uh advantageous position where it's
still a five hour flight
from the actual main matter of China but
but in in combination with the fact that
not necessarily just geographical but
also like especially if the West right
the US is saying like hey we support
that yeah then to uh own and or demolish
that ability to support what also not
just geographically to like them
specifically but even to like upend like
you know Western influence right so yeah
yeah I'm a little confused on how
America wants its citizens to feel about
it because sometimes it looks like
America wants everyone to be Pro Taiwan
and then other times it seems like it's
I think the uh the like maybe like 15 20
years ago the idea of like democracy for
all was like the idealism that was able
to be like the flag that you would maybe
hold right but now even even as an
American citizen it's really conflicting
in like the uh the perspective the views
the benefits as a country like I have no
phone and how integrated American
business has been with China that's the
part that's confusing to me is that when
whenever someone's talking about how to
feel they're saying that Taiwan should
be Sovereign but whenever someone's
making a decision it reflects China
being the ruler like all the business
decisions look to China and everything
it's verbal well we're definitely not a
democracy we're a capitalist society
that I think that's totally different
you know what I mean yeah Steve what
we're gonna say when it comes to
Taiwanese business Community they're
super integrated with China already
business relationships family right so
everybody knows that but when it comes
to Taiwan taiwan's looking at this thing
going like we get so much business from
China we don't want to have to deal with
this kind of conflict but the United
States is putting them in a horrible
position but basically saying hey we're
going to keep on poking the bear we're
going to keep on sending officials over
to Taiwan yeah to make the the the the
Chinese insecure about the proximity of
Taiwan to China that's that's what
America's really good at though right
well just be like that's not really our
problem but let's go ahead and make it a
problem see how we can benefit from it
so what like so within Hong Kong and um
Taiwanese like politics
there's China pro-china sympathizers
it's not like Democrats and Republicans
it's pro-china versus Independence in
both in both situations well Hong Kong
they lost right so obviously the
independence guys are backed by the West
so in it's a it's a situation of do they
want to go back to China or do they want
to be backed by the west and who's going
to win and so some people I think they
do business in China but they want to
remain
um independent in the sense of Western
influence right but when they're doing
business in China and when they enter
Taiwan right they say you are now like
if if we get it in a different way like
if we do actually get to change things
then you wouldn't just be like leaving
China and entering Taiwan they'd be
saying you are now entering vagina
and that's where it is that was worth it
in my eyes which is pretty which would
be pretty great
welcome to vagina
foreign
[Music]